on aimerait parfois savoir ce que
l'avenir nous réserve et un test de
dépistage génétique ça peut aider
certains craignent une maladie répandue
dans leur famille et il peut y avoir un
avantage à détecter des signaux le plus
tôt possible
mais ces informations devraient vous les
transmettre à votre assureur par exemple
non l'assureur a déjà le droit de vous
poser beaucoup de questions sur votre
état de santé sur les maladies que vous
avez déjà eu même sur vos antécédents
familiaux mais il ya une limite depuis
2010 est au pays les caractéristiques
génétiques d'une personne font partie
des motifs interdit de discrimination et
ça ça plaît aussi à votre employeur ou à
votre banque vous demander de passer un
test génétique ou même tenté de savoir
si vous en avez déjà subi un dans le
passé c'est criminel alors si vous
voulez savoir ce que l'avenir nous
réserve sachez que ce que vous
découvrirez ne regarde que vous passez
le mot
[Musique]